hello i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now tonight i'll
be joined by our speaker dr kate darling
who joins us from the mit media lab in
boston
for several years she's been studying
the way humans and computers and ai
interact and today she's going to be
talking to us about a potentially new
paradigm about the way we might think
about that interaction she's also been
talking about the way this is presented
in her book the new breed welcome dr
kate darling
thank you so much xander it is so great
to be here
so i love robots i love robots more than
i love spiked lemonade but i have a
three and a half year old and a newborn
baby at home and ever since i had kids
people will say something to me they'll
say kate
you must find it so interesting to watch
your children's brains develop and watch
them learn about the world
given that you study robots
now i love this i think it's a great
conversation starter it's wonderful that
people
ask this question given that they know
that i love robots so much but i am here
today
to tell you both why we so automatically
and instinctively compare robots to
ourselves to humans and also why i think
that that's the wrong way to think about
robots and artificial intelligence
as we move into the future
now another question i get a lot is what
is a robot there is actually no
universal definition of the word robot
people have different definitions
depending on the field that they come
from and people have different images in
their minds
of what the word robot actually is i
operate with the same definition as most
roboticists which is a robot is a
physical thing so not ai or a bot it has
to be physical it can sense the world it
can take in information think about what
to do next based on what it has sensed
about the world and then it can act on
its environment again
now that sounds pretty good but when you
drill down on that definition it gets a
little fuzzy at the edges i remember
when i first got to mit and i was so
excited to see the truly cutting-edge
work being done in robotics you know the
robots that we've been told over and
over again are going to take everyone's
jobs and take over the world
and i quickly discovered that there's a
massive discrepancy between the public
perception of where the world is in
robotics and where we actually are so
from what i've seen trust me
for most robots if you ever feel
threatened you can just dump a bucket of
water over them and you should be
absolutely fine
now that's not to say that we shouldn't
be thinking about
what
robots mean for the future of work for
the future of humanity that's something
that i think about a lot
i just come at it from a slightly
different perspective on our future and
that starts with a unique aspect of
robots that i'm especially interested in
which is our self-projection
for example
something that i think is fascinating is
the fact that there's a japanese
manufacturing company
that will have its employees do
exercises in the morning to warm up
their bodies for their day on the
assembly line
and this company which also has robots
working in the factory will have the
robots do the same exercises with their
arms in order to be perceived more like
colleagues and less as machines
isn't that a little bit weird
or i think it's interesting that when
boston dynamics released the following
video
everyone in robotics watched this video
and said wow the robot didn't fall over
but then there were quite a lot of other
people who watched this who expressed
more
negative emotions about what was
happening in the video
and it actually got to the point where
peta the animal rights organization was
getting so many phone calls that they
had to issue a press statement
now peta didn't really care much about
this they said they weren't going to
lose any sleep over this because it
wasn't a real dog
but i'm interested in this i am
interested
in the fact that despite all knowledge
to the contrary
people will consciously or
subconsciously treat robots like living
things
now i was at a conference a couple of
years ago getting a spiked lemonade at
the bar and i met this guy
let's call him scott because that was
his name and scott asked me what i was
interested in and i said i'm interested
in the fact that people consciously or
subconsciously treat robots like living
things
and scott said
i don't buy it
we talked for a long time over lemonade
i could not convince him so scott's
perspective was this this is a
generational issue he said
sure maybe our generation we grew up
with star wars maybe we will reflexively
apologize when we stumble over a
delivery robot on the sidewalk maybe
we'll name all of our robots but newer
generations that grow up with this
technology everywhere they're going to
treat robots just like any other device
now like i said i could not convince
scott of this as we parted ways but look
sure part of this is the influence of
science fiction and pop culture and part
of it is the novelty of the technology
so in 2015 when this hitchhiking robot
got beat up in philadelphia
people were really upset about it but
they might have been upset about it
because they had never seen a
hitchhiking robot before and they really
got into that narrative
but there's a piece to our perception of
robots that goes deeper than that and
that is our anthropomorphism we have
this inherent tendency to project
human-like traits qualities emotions on
to non-humans
we do this especially to animals
people will project emotions onto their
pets that may or may not actually be
there in fact
science
shows often that we get it completely
wrong and that the animals don't have
the emotions that we believe that they
do
uh but it's not just living things we
will project onto
things that are created in the image of
something lifelike like a stuffed animal
we will see faces and random objects or
car headlights we do this from a very
very early age one of the first things
that infants learn to recognize is faces
and they don't even have to be real
faces they can just be black and white
images on a screen so this is very
ingrained in us we do this in order to
interpret the world around us and make
sense of our world and relate to
anything around us and one of the things
that we also respond very strongly to is
movement
studies show that our brains are
constantly scanning our environments and
trying to separate things into objects
and agents and that makes sense
evolutionarily because we had to watch
out for the agents in the past
but what's happening now
is we have this new kind of object that
moves like an agent and that tricks our
brains into projecting intent and life
onto any of this movement that we can't
quite anticipate what it's going to do
next and you see this happen even with
the most simple robots take the roomba
vacuum cleaner
not the most sophisticated robot in the
world it's basically just a disc that
moves around your floor to clean it but
the fact that it that it's moving around
on its own will cause people to name the
roomba over 80 percent of roombas have
names
i don't know the statistics for your
regular handheld dyson i guarantee you
they're lower people will feel bad for
the roomba when it gets stuck somewhere
i was visiting the company that makes
the roomba
a few years ago and they had all these
stories of people who would send in
their roombas for repair and they would
turn down the offer of a brand new
replacement vacuum saying no we want you
to fix meryl sweep and send her back to
us now a more extreme example of this is
military robots there have been these
bomb disposal units that the united
states military has used in iraq and
afghanistan they are designed to let
soldiers hang back out of harm's way
a lot of them are just remote controlled
and only partially autonomous but
soldiers will treat them like pets they
gave them names they gave them medals of
honor
they would hold funerals with gun
salutes for them when they couldn't be
repaired there are even some stories of
soldiers risking their lives to save uh
the robots on the battlefield that they
didn't want to leave behind peter singer
writes about this in his book wired for
war
now the interesting thing here is that
these robots like the roomba are not
designed to look like anything special
they're basically just sticks on treads
and they're already having this effect
and that brings me to the element of
design that can enhance this even
further
now there are a lot of robots out there
that move in very biologically inspired
ways the reason for this is often
practical so boston dynamics is a
company that makes very biologically
inspired robots the reason that they do
this is practical
animals have evolved over billions of
years to be really efficient in
navigating different terrains so it
makes sense to borrow from that anatomy
when we are trying to design robot
locomotion but it's also very very
difficult to watch these robots move
around and not feel like they have some
sort of agency
now at the end of that conference where
i met my lemonade friend scott we
actually bumped into each other again
this was this robotics and space
conference there were a lot of demos and
scott said that he had seen a demo that
made him think more about this
and the thing he had seen was this a
very biologically inspired dragonfly
robot so it had wings and it could fly
around
and it looked like a dragonfly and the
thing that he noticed was
not the robot but the people in the room
watching the robot he said that they
were totally transfixed they could not
take their eyes off of this thing that
was buzzing around their heads and he
said you know what kate
maybe you're right maybe we are built
this way but i still don't buy it
and i said oh come on man but we shook
hands and
we decided that the next few decades are
going to be very very interesting to
watch because this is something that can
be designed intentionally and that's
what social robotics is all about
social robots are robots that are
intentionally designed to mimic cues
movements sounds whatever that people
automatically subconsciously associate
with states of mind
and this works really well
i first got really into this topic when
i bought a toy called a pleo it's a baby
dinosaur robot that came out in 2007.
so this is the pleo
the pleo is a very cool toy that i
initially bought because it has all
these cool motors and touch sensors and
an infrared camera in the snout and it
mimics lifelike behavior really well and
one of the things it has is a tilt
sensor so
it'll know what direction it's facing
i thought this was really cool and i
would show it off to my friends and
i would tell my friends to hold it up by
the tail because this is what happens
when you hold the plio up by the tail
[Music]
it mimics pain and distress
so i would show this off to my friends
and
some of my friends held it up for a
really long time and watched it squirm
and that started to make me
uncomfortable i realized i would ask
people to put it back down and say
that's enough
put him back down and then i would pet
the robot to make it stop crying
and that was really interesting because
i knew exactly how the robot worked and
i still felt compelled to comfort it
so that sparked a curiosity in me and
fast forward a few years i did a
workshop
with my friend jonas gosselt at a
conference called lyft in geneva we took
five of these baby dinosaur robots we
gave them to five groups of people
we had each group name their robot and
play with it interact with it we had
them do a little fashion show with the
robots where they dressed them up in
pipe cleaners and construction paper
just so that we could
personify them a little and then after
about 45 minutes to an hour we unveiled
a hammer and a hatchet and a knife and
we told them to torture and kill the
robots
now this turned out to be pretty
dramatic we obviously wanted it to be
dramatic but it turned out to be more
dramatic than we expected it to be
we had initially thought okay
there's probably going to be a split of
people in the room some people are going
to say oh so what it's just a robot and
some people are going to have more of a
problem with the violence
and we wanted to ratchet up the violence
and see how the split in the room
changed and instead everyone just
absolutely refused to even hit the baby
dinosaur robots we finally had to
threaten to destroy all of the robots
unless someone took a hatchet to one of
them
and this poor guy volunteered and we all
stood in a circle around him
and he brought the hatchet down on the
on the robot's neck and people kind of
winced and looked away
and then there was this half joking half
serious moment of silence in the room
for the fallen robot
so that was a really interesting day
now this wasn't science this was not a
scientific experiment this was not a
controlled setting there were a lot of
social dynamics
but it inspired some later research that
i did at mit with my colleagues cynthia
brazile and palash
and for this research instead of using
really cute evocative baby dinosaurs we
used something much more simple we used
hex bugs which are these toys that move
around like insects in a life-like way
but they're very basic and simple and we
had people come into the lab and smash
them with mallets and we wanted to know
two things so we wanted to know
would people hesitate more to hit the
hex bugs if like we do so often with
robots we give them a name and a
backstory so we say this is frank
frank's favorite color is red he likes
to play and then the second thing we
wanted to know was how people's
hesitation to hit the hex bugs related
to their natural tendencies for empathy
so we did psychological empathy testing
with people and we found that people who
scored low on empathic concern for
others in general
they didn't seem to care much about
frank they would just hit frank and
people who scored higher on empathic
concern they would hesitate more or
sometimes even refuse to hit the hex
bugs
so that was just a little study
but it is part of a large and growing
body of research in human robot
interaction that shows that we respond
genuinely to the cues that these
machines give us and we respond even if
we know perfectly well that none of this
is real
okay so why does this matter
i think it matters because what's
happening right now all over the world
is that robots are moving from being
kind of behind the scenes in factories
manufacturing behind walls and cages and
they're coming into shared spaces
spaces where
they are interacting with people
workplaces households public areas so we
have these machines that can sense and
think and make autonomous decisions and
learn
and they're not alive and they can't
feel but people feel differently about
them than they do about other devices
and that is such an important thing to
understand
as we start to integrate this technology
that people treat it differently
and in some ways this is even really
useful we are already seeing some pretty
cool applications in health and
education that specifically rely on
people treating a robot like a living
thing or like a social actor on them
even developing an emotional connection
to a robot so for example there's some
very intriguing research
on autistic children and using robots as
a tool in therapy
and the robots in this context aren't
used as a replacement for
a therapist or a parent
the robots are actually facilitating
conversations between the child and
the adult in the room and the
researchers aren't quite sure why robots
are so useful in this context but they
think it's because for these kids the
robot is clearly something social for
any of us a robot we'll treat it like
something social but the kids also
understand that the robot doesn't come
with all the baggage of humans and so it
can actually facilitate some of the
conversations that we want to be having
now it's not just in this context there
are also
a lot of
studies being run on using robots in
education using robots to help kids be
more curious about different aspects of
learning and again this is not to
replace teachers but rather to be used
as a supplemental additional tool in a
classroom setting
and then there's therapy robots like the
paro baby seal that's used in nursing
homes and with dementia patients this
one has been around for a while
it's a very very cute baby harpsil robot
it responds to your touch it makes these
little movements and sounds it's pretty
simple
but it has
quite an effect on the people who use it
um it lowers their blood pressure
it can calm them it gives them the sense
of nurturing something in a context
where their lives have been reduced to
being taken care of by others
now the first response that i often get
to paro
is
oh my gosh kate i can't believe that we
are living in a dystopia where we give
people robots instead of human care
i think that that's a very um justified
thing to say
uh because we shouldn't be replacing
human caretakers with robots that's a
terrible idea uh but here's where i want
to point out what i think is a huge
problem in a lot of our conversations
around robots in our casual
conversations in our news media even
among roboticists themselves and that is
that we
often subconsciously compare robots to
humans and artificial intelligence to
human intelligence
now of course we do this given
everything that i've just told you about
how we anthropomorphize robots and
project ourselves onto them
but we do it constantly we do it in our
stock photo images if you google image
search artificial intelligence you get a
bunch of images of human brains and
humanoid robots and human heads but we
do this also in our conversations about
robots replacing jobs one-to-one we do
this in our conversations about
intelligence like comparing my
children's brains to to ai but this
analogy does not make any sense at all
so on the one hand we already have
robots that are smarter than people we
have robots that can do endless
calculations that can beat us at chess
at go at jeopardy that can recognize
patterns and data that we would never
see
and then on the other hand
people are also much much smarter than
machines
it used to be that if you asked apple's
voice assistant siri to call you an
ambulance she would literally call you
an ambulance because she didn't
understand the context now of course
apple fixed this once it became known
but they probably had to fix it by hand
because
siri even today if you try to have a
conversation with her you will probably
give up pretty quickly that's not to say
that machines
aren't smart it's not to say that
they're not becoming smarter it's to say
that machines understand and see and
learn about the world differently than
we do
and so the question to me is not can we
eventually at some point in the future
recreate human intelligence the question
to me is
why would we want to do that in the
first place
when we can create something different
so it shouldn't be our goal to recreate
ourselves it's actually more useful to
create something that's supplemental
and i actually just wrote a book called
the new breed that tries to challenge
and break this mold of subconsciously
thinking of robots like humans by
offering a different analogy
this is an analogy that is familiar to
us that acknowledges that robots are
different from toasters in that they can
make their own decisions and learn about
the world and it's one that changes some
of these conversations and what i think
are pretty important ways
so if we come back to the baby seal
robot the paro
pardo is not designed to replace human
caregivers what paro is designed to
replace is animal therapy in contexts
where we can't use real animals for
reasons of health and hygiene and safety
but we can use the robot and it works
because people will consistently treat
the robot more like an animal than a
device
and it's not just in the social robotics
context if you think about it throughout
history we've used animals for work for
weaponry for companionship we
domesticated them because their skill
sets are different from ours not because
they do what we do
because they're different and that's
useful we've used oxen to plow our
fields for millennia we've used horses
to travel the world in new ways here is
the original hobby photography drone in
the early 1900s there was a german
pharmacist who was using pigeons to
deliver medicine which is something
we're starting to do with drones in
remote locations today
and one day he had the wild idea to put
cameras on the pigeons to see if they
could take aerial photographs
and turns out they could and of course
later the cia adopted this to create spy
pigeons but pigeons also delivered mail
for thousands of years letting us
communicate with each other in totally
new ways
now animals not only have physical
abilities but also sensing abilities
that are way better than ours and
incredibly useful
this for example is an official united
states navy echolocation device
in the 60s and 70s both the united
states and the soviet navy started
marine mammal training programs because
marine mammals have amazing echolocation
systems
so they use them to detect lost
underwater equipment and mines there are
some rumors that they strapped harpoons
to them and made them into weapons as
well
but the united states also used both
robots and dolphins in the gulf wars to
look for mines
and in fact the dolphin program is still
in place because even though they've
tried to phase out the dolphins and
replace them with robots the dolphins
are still in many ways better than the
technology here's also the
original sensory equipment used in the
mines the canary in the coal mine and i
could go on and on right there are so
many examples of how we are using
robots today in roles that we've
previously used animals in but the point
that i want to make is not that animals
and robots are the same the point that i
want to make is that
moving away from this constant
quasi-human comparison
opens our minds to new possibilities
it's a really useful thought exercise it
helps challenge the idea that robots and
ai can will or should replace people
the true potential of robotics and
artificial intelligence is not to
recreate what we already have
it's for us to partner with these
technologies and what we're trying to
achieve
i think this human comparison also lends
itself to some rhetoric that's pretty
misleading
so over the past five decades you've
probably seen some headlines that look
like this
no jobs blame the robots
well that headline would be a little
more accurate if it was no jobs blame
company decisions driven by unbridled
corporate capitalism
not such a pithy headline but more
accurate because it's not the robots
taking the jobs right thinking of robots
as quasi-humans giving them this agency
in our language really lends itself to a
determinism about our future and about
the automation of labor when in reality
we have choices we don't like to see
this but we have choices we could be
using technology to help people do a
better job rather than trying to
automate them away
if you look at warehouse workers today
it's kind of like that charlie chaplin
movie modern times where companies have
automated as much of the process as they
can and so they're treating the human
workers like a part of the machine the
they have scan guns that count down the
seconds between tasks they make them do
things that they are clearly hoping that
they can eventually automate once the
technology gets better but that's not
the only way to think about or handle
human labor like a replaceable commodity
so take for example the united states
patent and trademark office i know that
a lot of patent and trademark offices
are dealing with the problem that
you have patent examiners that get tons
of applications on their desk they need
to decide whether any invention is new
enough to warrant patent protection and
so technically they have to sift through
all of the world's information in order
to make that determination which is
impossible
and
so you know one of the things that the
united states patent trademark office
could have done which i have seen
companies do is they could have said
i wonder if we could train artificial
intelligence
on you know the historic data that we
have and have it make determinations
that are you know have a slightly better
hit rate than the examiners because even
if it's just slightly better than the
very poor job that we're doing right now
then we can get rid of all these people
and not have to pay them their salaries
no instead what they said was how can we
use this technology to help our people
do a better job and so they started
looking for ways to use ai to surface
some of the prior art that the examiners
wouldn't have found on their own
and then letting the humans do what they
do best which is make that judgment call
that determination
so
how can we use robots to help people do
a better job rather than replace them
how can we use robots to help people be
more productive to leverage what people
are good at and enjoy doing while
automating the things that robots are
good at which tend to be the uncreative
dirty dangerous or dull things that
people don't like doing anyway
now unfortunately while employers could
be thinking creatively about supporting
workers whether that's in their current
jobs or supporting them through
transitions because this still requires
a lot of disruption to our current way
of doing things
these choices are driven by a broader
political and economic system that sets
short-term corporate profit incentives
and does treat workers like a commodity
and that is a really really difficult
thing to address and change
but that's the conversation we should be
having instead of this the robots are
coming for our jobs technological
determinism that i see everywhere
now another area where i think we can
and need to shift the conversation is
when we talk about law specifically
responsibility for harm
i have seen too many lawyers argue that
we are currently at a unique moment in
history because we are developing
machines that can make their own
decisions some of which not even the
creators or users could anticipate
and to deal with the problem a lot of
the proposed solutions are along the
lines of
can we hold the robots themselves
accountable either by programming them
with certain baked in rules or ethics or
the eu has even had a proposal to create
an electronic personhood to be able to
make the machines themselves responsible
now this is not completely out of left
field because we've created personhood
for corporations and other non-humans
but i think we don't talk enough
currently about how
there is legal precedent for
unanticipated autonomous behavior
we've had to deal with the question of
responsibility for animal-caused harm
ever since the beginning of laws known
to humankind that dealt with what
happens if your ox wanders off into the
street and gores somebody unexpectedly
whose fault is that who has to pay for
that and different societies had
different answers depending on their
culture but the point is we have this
whole smorgasbord of ways that we have
dealt with autonomously caused harm in
the past and we should be drawing on
some of that when we think about this in
the future again the point is not that
robots and animals are the same the
point is that thinking about this
analogy gives us some different options
and most importantly it helps us start
from a different place
because when you compare robots to
animals it suddenly feels very different
to argue that they should be accountable
we don't expect animals to abide by our
rules and moral codes a zoo can't let
the tiger wander around the zoo freely
and then when it eats someone point to
the tiger and say oh well you know we
couldn't how could we anticipate that we
trained it to be really nice we did our
best
but we're already seeing corporations
and governments try to distance
themselves from responsibility and blame
the algorithms in their rhetoric when
something goes wrong and that worries me
because in the past some of our
analogies for technology have actually
influenced some of our law and policy
so two researchers richardson smart call
the human robot comparison the android
fallacy and i think that that is
happening here and we need to be very
aware of it
now i do not think that it is possible
to get rid of our anthropomorphism i do
think we need to be like i said
appropriately aware of it and we need to
guide it where we can for example when
we're talking about liability for
example when we're talking about the
future of work
but i think what it also means is that
we're going to see certain things happen
as robots become more part of our daily
lives for example
socially
if you think about it
throughout history we've treated most
animals like tools and products and some
animals as companions
i think it's entirely plausible that
we're going to start doing the same
thing with robots treat most of them
like tools and products and some of them
like our companions
now we know what scott would say to this
and here's what i want to say to scott
look maybe you're right
maybe once robots are ubiquitous we will
treat them just like any other device
but i just don't buy it
and i think that the research on human
robot interaction is not only
interesting
but important i think that what's most
fascinating to me about this research is
that it's teaching us more about
ourselves it's teaching us about human
psychology empathy
how we relate to others
if we look at the history of animal
rights for example it doesn't really
match the philosophical reasons that a
lot of us believe in like preventing
suffering our actual history shows that
we care way more about preventing
certain types of human behavior or
protecting the animals that we have an
emotional or a cultural relationship to
when it comes to animals we don't truly
care as much about inherent criteria
like consciousness or suffering even
though we think that we do and we want
to many of us
and we've kind of ignored that hypocrisy
but what human robot interaction
research can do is hold up a mirror and
make us confront some uncomfortable
truths about ourselves one of which may
be that we care more about a fluffy baby
seal robot than a living breathing slimy
slug
now that's not to say that we can't
shift our behavior if we don't like
being this way but it requires seeing it
acknowledging our social tendencies
helps us better navigate technology
integration and it's also helping us see
i think some of the real issues that we
may be facing in the near future because
what keeps me up at night is not robot
takeovers it's
privacy and data security it's the ways
that robots could be used to manipulate
people not just for their own benefit in
health care and education but for
someone else's benefit so setting aside
some of our moral panic and our
determinism about the future
really helps us be more clear-eyed about
our challenges and about our choices it
helps us think outside of the box it
helps us lean into the positives
and it helps us intentionally build
technology with the goal of benefiting
people
and if we can do that then i for one
am excited to welcome our new robot
partners and to work together to shape a
future that supports
human flourishing
thank you very much
thank you so much kate that was really
great and i would like to welcome you on
live from your home in boston
hi
good to see you
good to see you too after hearing your
talk i was reminded of uh i was driving
through san francisco and was going by a
park and there was this new robotic lawn
mower that was
going down
mowing this lawn of the park but then
like 20 feet behind it is this guy
operating the robot
which i thought was really odd right
because they've now taken a job that was
a blue collar entry-level job that was
guy riding the mower and replaced it
with probably someone that cost four
times as much per hour who's now a robot
technician driving the robot 40 feet
behind it and i was very like they're
not going to just unleash you know
robotic lawnmower robots in parks in san
francisco around humans so clearly
there's this human thing that where and
i've seen this over and over again where
actually robotics isn't being introduced
really just makes jobs that were
entry level or blue collar into robotics
engineer jobs which are kind of more
difficult to fill and more expensive but
i wonder what your thoughts are on on
this kind of the way that you know
robots are kind of being moved into our
lives i think for a technological demo
reason instead of the truly saving of
time and money reason
oh that's so well put i think that is
true that we are seeing a lot of robots
as you know technological demos or just
you know
pr
draws for attention and people because
they can't actually replace jobs i do
want to push back a little bit on the
idea that it always goes in the
direction of
well now someone operating the robot is
a higher skilled worker because you also
have the case where you know you have
the self-checkout things at grocery
stores that are always malfunctioning
and you have someone there who's
performing the labor of helping the
customers navigate you know the
technologies it's not working properly
and sometimes that is invisible labor
that doesn't even get compensated like
suddenly you you have people doing more
work or like more annoying work that
doesn't ever get seen
we also and i don't know if you have
been to a stop and shop on the east
coast this is a grocery store that we
have
we have these robots named marty that
roam the aisles that are six feet tall
and they have these googly eyes and all
the robot does is um it tries to detect
hazards on the floor and then alert an
employee to come clean the hazard uh and
so
uh you know i've
i and uh one of my students daniela de
paola have spent a lot of time in stop
and shop watching this robot and
watching it you know flag people to come
over for tiny pieces of cilantro and
watch the employees like walk over and
sigh heavily and like press a button on
the robot to make it keep going so you
know you have i i would say the most
ideal case of
this uh disruption is if you have a
robot like the lawnmower robot and then
you have the person who is previously
driving the lawn mower you train them to
be able to operate the robot and that
happens sometimes that's happened with
some of the sewer robots in india
but i think that's really what we want
we want to be able to train people so
that they can have a more fulfilling job
and
instead of either getting rid of them
and hiring someone who's higher you know
has more qualifications or
you know having them do
the horrible cleanup work without
getting compensated
thanks um and we're going to be bringing
in kevin kelly one of the founders of
long now on the senior maverick at wired
hi
absolutely great
kate i i think your book is fantastic
the new breed and um
i highly recommend it you know i i think
you're
introducing the idea of
a better
model for us thinking about these
varieties and pluralities of artificial
intelligences embodied into robots is to
think of them as animals either pets or
domesticated workers and
what's interesting to me about about
your suggestion is that
as you note in the book that once you
begin to look at our own
um
ideas about animal rights we're totally
conflicted and we're completely
inconsistent i mean basically if you eat
meat and are concerned about animal
rights
you're a hypocrite right i mean in some
sense it's because we don't
know what animal intelligence is like we
don't know what their con consciousness
is like we we don't know so many things
so it's very very messy
and at first i thought well that's like
um that's like a bug but actually
that might be
that it might actually be the feature
the whole point of treating things like
these
robots like animals is because we don't
know what
intelligence is in machines either we
don't know what consciousness is we
don't have any idea and so we can take
this model where it's already messy and
we don't know what we're doing and we
apply it to the robots to help us figure
out what it is that we're thinking about
so it's kind of like a really great
first step
is that kind of the thesis
that is absolutely what the third part
of the book was trying to to go for that
it's that's why this is a useful analogy
because it
you know
let's take a step back from these
conversations about you know what is
consciousness and ai and and look at you
know historically how we've dealt with
animals this other being that can sense
and think and make autonomous decisions
and learn and
what we've what we've learned is we
don't we don't have any answers there
either so it's a good place to start
yeah well it's great work i highly
recommend people follow up and thank you
for your fantastic talk thanks so much
thanks kevin yeah
that was great
um one other thing i mean i think we
have you know we have certain types of
lessons where where robots have crept
into our lives and taken over things
that actually
do take a human job but it seems to have
been fine we talked a little bit earlier
about things like washing machines and
clothes washing machines as well as uh
dish washing machines where i know here
at here at our bar if the dishwasher
goes down we have to hire a human that
night to start washing dishes so it's a
it's a true replacement but um you know
what what do you think is the reason
that those robots that have crept into
our lives um and do human tasks are seem
to be we don't seem to have empathy for
them when they don't work we hate them
we don't feel bad for them
why do you think that is
well yeah i i think it has to do with
our very messy definition of what a
robot is right uh sometimes it's any new
fancy technology that has some sort of
uh like automatic can do something
automatically is a robot and then once
it becomes more
integrated into our lives or workplaces
it becomes a tool like a dishwasher
and i also think it gets to
our uh you know the weird ways that we
treat some robots like they're alive and
some robots like tools and
depending on their function it depends a
lot on the design i talked a lot about
design but it also kind of depends on
the function so
yes we've had we've had a lot of
technological disruption
and uh it's it's funny how we focus so
much on robots and artificial
intelligence as like this major
disrupter that's so different from the
other disruptors and i think that has a
lot to do with our own fears and less to
do with the technology itself
yeah yeah indeed it seems like there's
certainly no you know no real
feelings for the office printer when it
goes down other than hatred
[Laughter]
that seems to be a different type of
robot for sure um
and
one of the questions from the feed from
our youtube feed from anton
he's asking you know
how and when should we allow robots to
say no to us is there is there an ethics
of when robots should answer no to a
human request
that's a really good question
so
uh yeah so the first time i encountered
this was there was this
radio lab podcast years ago like over 10
years ago
and they interviewed freedom baird who
was a roboticist at the media lab who
way preceded me um and she had bought a
furby and she she carried the furby
around with her and when it when the
furby the the old furby i think the new
furby too but when they get flipped
upside down they say me no like
and they start to protest so they start
to say no we just started to tell you to
do something differently
um and so she realized that that made
her feel bad and she would take the
furby out and put it back upright and uh
so so she started thinking more about
how we react to robots um
but the
yeah it's a question that toy designers
are already facing like do you
design a toy that says ow that hurt me
when you hit it
please stop uh or do you design it to
not react and i i think it very much
depends on the situation but it's
something that we need to be very
sensitive to because you know in some
ways saying no
might even
lend itself to people than wanting to
torture it even more in some cases and
is that good are you then training
people to override consent i think we
just need to be really careful
especially when it comes to kids
as to you know how how these
interactions are are being monitored um
and how we design these toys and and the
first step is really understanding that
we do subconsciously treat them like
living things
yeah i mean obviously the asimov's three
laws kind of in some way cover this
right like you can't train a robot to
hurt another human that's where robots
supposed to say no right
so it's one of those places and i'm
wondering those three laws are they've
been kind of amazingly
useful in thinking about robots even
just in films and things like that as we
imagine our future is there thoughts on
more
robotics laws or more any consortiums of
roboticists that are talking about this
as a broad field that we need to you
know have have good robot laws
well to me i mean the usefulness of the
laws is the fact that asimov showed over
and over again how they don't work right
they you know
yeah so i mean what it really what it
illustrates is how complicated it is to
rely on the programming of the machine
to follow
any kind of rules that we give it
especially if that's like an ethical or
moral code which we haven't even agreed
on as humans so
it's i i think it's useful in that sense
um
but people often forget that right
they forget that really the stories are
about how the laws how laws like that
don't work and they say oh maybe we can
develop some laws like asimov's so
so it's kind of i wonder
you know how he would feel about the
fact that people have kind of taken that
in the opposite direction
so i want to ask you know this this this
book is fantastic and it's coming out
and where are you where are you heading
next with your research and thoughts on
this stuff i'd love to
hear about what you might be doing next
well we we had a bunch of experiments
planned for the fall and now we're
waiting to see because we are currently
still in a global pandemic waiting to
see if that's
possible because you know
my passion is
working with people and robots and
so but uh
some of the experiments that i have
queued up are around consumer protection
and policy issues around emotional
persuasion um
through robots
and also some uh just it's we live in
such an interesting time i mean
uh especially where you are where robots
are coming out onto the streets uh it's
so interesting to see these robots that
engineers have developed and like
they've
they they put so much effort into like
you said like just getting them to
function right and then sometimes they
just don't take into account what
happens when you put the robot in in an
environment with people and psychology
and emotions come into play um and it's
so funny to watch like some of the
mistakes that are being made and some of
the successes and to understand that
human robot interaction as a field is
really
important and growing in importance as
we try to integrate this technology
yeah it is i've seen them on the street
i've seen people both help them and hurt
them uh these delivery robots on the
streets so there seems to be definitely
a mixed reaction to these things well um
thank you so much for joining us and for
this talk um and i hope that at some
point we can have you here for a spiked
lemonade uh here at the interval uh we
can have this discussion further thank
you so much thank you so much for having
me
and thank you our audience uh and look
forward to having you at one of our
talks in the future
[Music]